herzlich willkommen freunde bei einer
etwas anderen mod review und zwar habe
ich dieses format eine mod review mir
neu ausgedacht beziehungsweise werde ich
nur dieses eine mal anwenden außer
vielleicht wenn noch mal so ein wenig an
motto raus kommt und zwar viele haben
schon erkannt es ist der sonic at shader
motto der viele schatten und auch
allgemein ein paar neue features zu
eurem minecraft hinzufügt zum beispiel
dass die komplette belichtung anders ist
die farben sind total heller geworden
allgemein das tag machtverhältnis es nun
deutlich angenehmer und es sind halt
schatten dazu gekommen natürlich
verursacht dieser mod ziemlich viele
lecks weil es haben nicht alle ein super
gamer pc mit einer super grafikkarte
aber dafür habe ich und damit ich euch
quasi die fragen abnehme hey luca wie
macht man das schaut einfach in die
beschreibung dort steht ein link zu
meiner minecraft punkt klar die ich dazu
verwendet habe und dort lautet euch
einfach die minecraft die in der
beschreibung steht und packt die bei
euch in den ordner in minecraft und dann
habt ihr die shader schon bei euch drin
und zwar das neue format wird ganz
einfach sein ich zeige euch ein paar
szenen aus dem mod und ich kommentiere
dazu ein wenig das wird nur bei diesem
shader motto oder vielleicht noch ein
paar anderen worten der fall sein aber
ich werde erst mal testen und schauen
wie das ankommt also alle tiere allem
ops auch diese zertifikate in den mpc
davon haben schatten alle blöcke haben
schatten und das einzige was vielleicht
ein wenig blöd ist dass die fackel nun
nicht mehr so viel licht geben das seht
ihr vielleicht gerade vielleicht aber
auch er später ich weiß es gerade gar
nicht und ich würde jetzt einfach mal
sagen wenn ihr den mut haben wollt
schaut einfach in die beschreibung
donald und euch meine minecraft punkte
und packt ihr euch in den ordner in
minecraft rein und dann habt ihr die
schatten und ihr könnt das natürlich
auch noch alles komplett in den
einstellungen anpassen aber ich würde
erstmal sagen ich halte jetzt erstmal
meinen mund und ihr könnt euch das alles
jetzt noch so brillant und einzigartig
wie dieser motor ist einfach ganz
gechillt ansehen also dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns in der nächsten
mottoshow